on a des nouvelles de valérie bénaïm
notre chien oui regardez nous envoyer
une photo d'un drop alors pourquoi cette
photo parce que c'est le hashtag qu'a
fait marrer tout le monde sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui et oui quel
est le seul endroit au monde où tout le
monde est logé à la même enseigne
évidemment les toilettes et à hashtag
qui est arrivé aujourd'hui s'est tous
égaux hashtag tous égaux donc en fait il
ya des auteurs d'autres ils sont amusés
à mettre des personnes très importantes
et les imaginer aux toilettes
regardez regardez ce que ça fait
regardez barack obama ben il ya ma
classe
rim est comme la reine elizabeth très
bon call au regard des et bien sûr on à
raymond également regarder raymond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sa part maxime bernat on va les pays bas
la vie regardez valérie manet ville est
en fête autour et on se remet raymond
pour le team
ça
vous révélez je donne à la régie un 12
sur vous c'est pas un photomontage moi
je vous ai aux toilettes aussi et c'est
vrai c'est pas un montage c'est une
vraie c'est une vraie je les donne à la
région
ah oui bah oui mais oui ça c'est vrai
bayer cours et qu'on se bouge toujours
[Rires]
avec son calme était obligé visite
si justement face à l'escalier ou
presque on finira vidéo parce que je
n'avais pas été aussi mauvais qu'on
pouvait comme ça va vous ravir vous
serez problème on est venu parce que
j'ai fermé nature former la lune est
excusez moi votre chasse ne marche par
mois
[Applaudissements]